am 24 februar
2022 beginnt die von wladimir putin
befohlene russische invasion der ukraine
usa und eu reagieren in der folge mit
wirtschaftssanktionen in deutschland
stellt sich die frage nach
energiesicherheit und unsere
abhängigkeit von russland
denn mit beginn dieses angriffskrieges
in der ukraine ist eines allen klar
geworden deutschland hat eine aufgabe
wir müssen uns unabhängig machen von
russischen energieimporten
gibt es wege aus dieser abhängigkeit
drei deutsche atomkraftwerke sind noch
am netz sie liefern knapp sieben prozent
des strom anteils ende dieses jahres
werden sie abgeschaltet so ist es im
atomgesetz verankert
ist es zeit das zu überdenken
ich halte es schlicht für einen fehler
in einer solchen situation aus der
kernenergie auszusteigen
aus ethischer sicht glaube ich haben wir
momentan keine andere option außer die
laufzeiten zu verlängern doch es gibt
auch klare stimmen gegen eine
verlängerung der laufzeiten
und wenn man diese sehr ernsthafte lage
der krise
missbraucht für dieses wieder aufrufen
mühsam befriedeter gesellschaftlicher
konflikte dann ist das moralisch
verwerflich
ungeachtet des grundsätzlichen streits
ums thema kernenergie wäre eine
verlängerung der laufzeiten überhaupt
möglich eine suche nach antworten auf
fragen der sicherheit der
finanzierbarkeit der personellen
machbarkeit und der risiken von
atomkraft
[Musik]
die diskussion über kernenergie in
deutschland ist traditionell hoch
aufgeladen emotionalität und verhärtete
fronten auf beiden seiten eine sachliche
auseinandersetzung scheint unmöglich was
sind die gründe zum einen gab es
natürlich eine große werdender
bevölkerung nach dem unfall in
tschernobyl das was jetzt ukraine ist
das war natürlich näher an deutschland
als in vielen anderen ländern
ist glaube ich aber auch nicht der haupt
ausschlaggebende grund ich glaube uns
ist vielleicht auch noch ein generelles
unbehagen eine kritischere haltung
gegenüber dem eigenen staat zu
beobachten das natürlich aus der aus der
vergangenheit aus den 30er jahren
generiert ein blick in die geschichte
der atomkraft
1972 gingen die ersten kommerziellen
atomkraftwerke in deutschland ans netz
40 neue atommeiler sollten bis 1985
entstehen mitte der siebziger jahre
beginnt die bewegung der atomkraftgegner
durch die katastrophe in tschernobyl
1986 schließen sich immer mehr menschen
an
mit dem kraftwerk in neckarwestheim ging
1989 das letzte atomkraftwerk in
deutschland ans netz
2001 schließlich verkündet die damalige
rot grüne regierung den atomausstieg der
aber von der ihr folgenden
schwarz-gelben 2010 wieder verschoben
wird
als ich angefangen habe 1975 war so dass
die bundesregierung gesagt hat bitte
baut mehr kernkraftwerke
und alle im patt im parlament waren
dafür und als ich nach der nach dem
unfall in fukushima war es so dass
keiner von den parteien im parlament
sich noch mit einem repräsentanten der
kerntechnik auf der straße sehen lassen
die katastrophe von fukushima im märz
2011 schockiert die welt keine vier
monate später beschließt die regierung
den deutschen ausstieg aus der
atomenergie
oftmals wird er gesagt dass der
atomausstieg in deutschland als reaktion
auf fukushima emotionale
kurzschlussreaktion war ich denke dass
es in teilen war eine
kurzschlussreaktion sicherlich aber
vermutlich eine sehr rationale einer
bundesregierung die wiedergewählt werden
wollte
auf der anderen seite hat man natürlich
auf die emotionen einer bevölkerung
reagiert und am dieses reagieren auf
emotionen ist sicherlich nie eine gute
idee
wäre die verlängerung der laufzeiten
deutscher kernkraftwerke in der
aktuellen situation angemessen falls
gleichzeitig die importe an steinkohle
aus russland und erdgas wegfallen
sollten dann kann es durchaus einen
unterschied machen ob wir strom aus
atomenergie
produzieren oder eben nicht
atomkraftwerke sind hilfreich um die
versorgungslage in europa zu entspannen
aber gleichzeitig kann sie einen kleinen
beitrag leisten
kein deutsches atomkraftwerk erteilt in
der aktuellen situation eine
dreherlaubnis
also fahren wir in die schweiz wollen
uns dort erklären lassen wie ein
kernkraftwerk zur versorgungssicherheit
beitragen kann
[Musik]
das kernkraftwerk gösgen erzeugt 8
milliarden kilowattstunden strom pro
jahr und deckt damit etwa 13 prozent des
schweizerischen stromverbrauchs
um die 550 mitarbeiter sind hier
beschäftigt
im ausstellungsraum sehen wir wie die
anlage im einzelnen aufgebaut ist
wie in den drei deutschen kraftwerken
ist der reaktor typ hier ein
druckwasserreaktor
aber wie funktioniert das ganze
eigentlich die strom entstehung passiert
über drei kreisläufe im ersten kreislauf
dem primärkreislauf findet die
kernspaltung statt das dadurch
aufgeheizte wasser wird in einen
wärmetauscher gepumpt von hier wird es
als dampf in den sekundär kreislauf
abgegeben der nicht radioaktiv belastet
ist und in die turbine geleitet
die beginnt zu rotieren und treibt den
mit ihr verbundenen generator an wo der
strom erzeugt wird
im nächsten wärmetauscher wird der dampf
wieder zu wasser das kühlt im dritten
kreislauf ab und wird zurück in den
reaktor geleitet
[Musik]
kraftwerksdirektor herbert meinecke
führt uns direkt zum herzstück der
anlage ins reaktorgebäude mit dem
druckbehälter
der eigentliche reaktor ist dort unter
dem quadratischen betonstein etwa zehn
meter tiefer eingehüllt und mit massen
an beton und dort werden die kerne
gespalten und geben die energie an das
wasser ab und von dort an die energie
erzeugt als
nächstes wird meinecke und dahin führen
wo alle fäden zusammenlaufen
aber zunächst zurück nach deutschland
noch liefern auch die letzten drei
kernkraftwerke in deutschland strom am
meisten davon isar 2 die betreiber des
akw isar 2 haben eine generelle
bereitschaft zum weiterbetrieb der
anlage signalisiert
wir hatten anfang märz vor dem
hintergrund des ukraine krieges und nur
in dieser ausnahmesituation unsere
bereitschaft signalisiert über die
rahmenbedingungen einer weiteren nutzung
von isar 2 zu sprechen ein sicherer
weiterbetrieb wäre technisch und
personell umsetzbar und könnte im
kommenden winter unterbrechungsfrei
erfolgen
anna veronika wendland technik
historikerin und experten für
reaktorsicherheit
würde den weiterbetrieb der anlage
befürworten zum beispiel in isar 2 da
ist der reaktorkern so ausgelegt worden
und so beladen worden dass die anlage
eigentlich jeden tag dieses jahres bis
zum 31 dezember volllast fahren könnte
das bedeutet aber automatisch auch das
dass diese reaktorkern ab dem ersten
januar 20 23 auch noch weiter betrieben
werden kann dann aber im so genannten
streck betrieb das heißt mit stetig
fallender leistung
felix christian matthes
forschungskoordinator für energie und
klimapolitik beim öko institut hingegen
sieht die verlängerung nicht als
problemlösung sondern problem
verschiebung
wenn man die kernkraftwerke wirklich
verlängern wollte müsste man neuen
brennstoff
bestellen den kann man nicht im
supermarkt kaufen und dann gibt es lange
fristen das heißt also selbst wenn man
das tun wollte würde man vermutlich ein
anderthalb oder zwei jahre warten müssen
damit der neue brennstoff da ist das
heißt in der problematischen phase der
krise die wir in den nächsten zwei bis
drei wintern haben würden die
kernkraftwerke nichts nützen
abgesehen von dieser streitfrage braucht
es vor allem gutes personal für den
weiterbetrieb der kernkraftwerke
besonders die reaktorfahrer
verantwortlich für den nuklearen teil
des kernkraftwerks durchlaufen sehr
spezialisierte ausbildungen
also wir sind hier im kommandoraum vom
kernkraftwerk gösgen im hintergrund sind
die arbeitsplätze vom reaktor operateur
und von turbine operateur
hier steht jetzt also hier in der nähe
vom chefpult und hier laufen alle fäden
zusammen alle meldungen laufen zusammen
hier wird das kraftwerk kontrolliert
angefahren abgefahren
verantwortungsvolle aufgaben die
ausbildungen in diesem bereich dauern
normalerweise mehrere jahre
man fängt an auf der anlage als anlagen
rundgänge macht den macht die erste
lizenz prüfung später geht es dann an
eine höhere fachschule für technik dort
wird dann reaktor operateurs wissen
vermittelt und es gibt entsprechende
prüfung so dass man hier auf einen
dieser beiden punkte sitzen darf
wenn man dann weiter die karriere machen
möchte und beschichtet werden dauert das
so bis so ab sechseinhalb jahre darf man
dann hier eine schicht gruppe führen
im reaktorraum werden wir unsere tour
fortführen
[Musik]
in deutschland haben viele mitarbeiter
der noch laufenden kraftwerke bereits
frührente vereinbarungen getroffen
für die schulung von neuem personal
fehlt die zeit
ullrich war es war von 2005 bis
2021 im aufsichtsrat der
sicherheitskommission für atomkraftwerke
in deutschland
der physiker hat sich mit der
personalfrage beschäftigt es gibt
natürlich auch personal die auf
ähnlichen anlagen schon gearbeitet haben
da sagt die vorschrift
für das personal das bei eine nach bei
einer umschulung oder beim wechsel des
kraftwerks frühestens nach einem halben
jahr die prüfung gemacht werden kann
und das dann
von diesen um geschulten personal
eigentlich dann aber schon leute 2023
und so weiter zur verfügung stehen man
muss dann eben sehen wie lange es
darüber hinaus gehen soll nicht also
auch wieder
eine vorgabe der politik das
personalproblem wäre mit einigem aufwand
in den griff zu bekommen aber würde sich
das überhaupt lohnen welchen beitrag
leistet die atomkraft zur stromerzeugung
in deutschland
im jahr 2021 liefern die damals noch
sechs laufenden atomkraftwerke knapp 13
prozent der gesamt strommenge
drei werden ende des jahres 21
abgeschaltet
im ersten quartal
2022 liefern deshalb die verbliebenen
drei nur noch 6,2 prozent
dennoch sehen ökonominnen und ökonomen
vorteile im verlängern der laufzeiten
falls die versorgungslage sich
verschlechtert
wenn man nur tatsächlich den ausfall von
erdgas kompensieren müsste im
strombereich dann sind ausreichend
kapazitäten an steinkohle und an
braunkohlekraftwerken verfügbar es sind
zum teil nicht ausgelastet es gibt auch
noch reservekapazitäten wenn aber eben
gleichzeitig die steinkohle wegfallen
würde nicht ersetzt wird und
erdgas wegfällt dann wird es etwas enger
was tatsächlich den ersatz dieser
russischen importe angeht und man kann
der der weiterbetrieb der atomkraftwerke
tatsächlich auch ein unterschied machen
atomkraftwerke könnten also einen teil
zur versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
beitragen aber was wären die
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
konsequenzen einer laufzeitverlängerung
[Musik]
kein atomkraftwerk funktioniert ohne den
kernbrennstoff angereichertes uran
herbert meinecke erklärt uns den prozess
also die brennelemente müssen eigentlich
spalt elemente heißen weil da brennt ja
nichts was passiert ist dass wir
schwermetall spalten und aus der
spaltung des schwermetalls kommt die
energie schwermetall ist in dem fall
uran und uran wird in minen abgebaut in
kanada in australien
auch in kasachstan in verschiedenen
gebieten
nachdem dieses uran abgebaut wird
abgebaut ist wird es angereichert so
dass wir es hier in so einem reaktor für
die erzeugung von energie benutzen
können kein atomstrom ohne uran daraus
ergibt sich ein zeitliches problem
wie schnell ist uran überhaupt zu
bekommen wie schnell kann es zu
brennstäben weiterverarbeitet werden und
welche neue abhängigkeiten würden
dadurch entstehen es handelt sich bei
uns herum drei akw s das heißt also
wesentlich weniger als wir langfristig
genutzt haben dass der neue
abhängigkeiten entstehen ist im prinzip
nicht zu erwarten ist und relativ wenige
ist würde sich über um eine überbrückung
handeln der aktuellen krise also
vermutlich fünf jahre wahrscheinlich
maximal das heißt neue abhängigkeiten
würden dadurch erst mal nicht geschaffen
nicht alle teilen diese einschätzungen
40 der europäischen uran importe kommen
augenblicklich aus russland und
kasachstan
russland ist ein spieler im kern
energiemarkt ein großer teil des urans
was verarbeitet wird im übrigens nicht
nur in europa sondern auch in den usa
stammt aus russland oder aus staaten die
mit russland eng verbundenen verbunden
sind das heißt also die abhängigkeit
besteht hier
vielleicht auf der zeitschiene ein
bisschen gestreckter aber genauso auch
andere länder weisen große uranreserven
auf allerdings ist der russische
staatskonzern rosatom über seine
beteiligungen an uran minen unter
anderem in kanada und den usa
zweitgrößter uranproduzent der welt was
das tatsächlich an abhängigkeit bedeutet
ist momentan nicht wirklich klar aber
ohne ross atom beteiligung würde die
beschaffung vermutlich teurer werden
neben alten und neuen abhängigkeiten
stellt sich die frage nach den
finanziellen herausforderungen einer
laufzeitverlängerung die stromerzeugung
aus bestehenden abgeschriebenen
atomkraftwerken ist relativ günstig das
heißt also die kosten könnten hier eben
dadurch entstehen dass man tatsächlich
die kraftwerksbetreiber quasi
entschädigen muss dafür dass sie die
kraftwerke erst mal per se weiter
betreiben
neben den ohnehin schon zugesagten
zahlungen an die betreiber für den
atomausstieg
kämen jetzt entschädigungen für den
ungeplanten weiterbetrieb der reaktoren
dazu
[Musik]
also als ökonom würde ich verschiedene
vor und nachteile versuchen zu
quantifizieren gegeneinander abzuwägen
atomkraftwerke sind wahnsinnig teuer zu
bauen wenn man sie mal gebaut hat die
rentieren sich quasi nur wenn man sie
dann auch ununterbrochen betreibt wenn
sie die ganze zeit strom produzieren wie
hier in der schweiz könnten also
kernkraftwerke auch bei uns weiterhin so
manche stromlücke füllen
bleibt die sicherheitsfrage wir sind
hier also mittendrin im kernkraftwerk im
prinzip wie so in der mitte einer
zwiebel um uns herum sind verschiedene
schalen die sicherstellen dass die
radioaktivität da bleibt wo sie ist
so der plan die gefahr wird aber
unterschiedlich eingeschätzt
die gefahren einschätzung der
kernenergie für laien es glaube ich sehr
sehr schwierig was man vermeiden muss in
diskurs sind 222 rapid fans auf der
einen seite die emotionen als
handlungsleitend zu nehmen in dem fall
die angst vor ein vor den gefahren eines
nuklearen endlager vor einem störfall
oder sie komplett zu negieren und da
würden würde ich mir wie viele leute
wünschen dass das bei den parteien
stärker an kommt die rolle die emotionen
spielen können müssen aber welches eben
auch nicht spielen dürfen die
katastrophe von fukushima auslöser des
deutschen ausstiegs aus der atomkraft
ist für viele der beweis für die massive
gefahr die der einsatz von
kernkraftwerken mit sich bringt wenn man
auf eine technologie setzt die ein hohes
risiko beinhaltet dann muss man sich
immer klar sein dass wenn dieses risiko
sich auf die eine oder andere art und
weise materialisiert ob man schwierige
schweißnähte entdeckt oder ob man große
unfälle erlebt dass man sehr schnell auf
unsicherem grund ist
andere haben gerade vor dem hintergrund
von fukushima ihre einschätzung zur
atomkraft verändert
gestand der kernenergie schon immer
neutral gegenüber aber mit fukushima
habe ich mich ähnlich wie kollegen die
vorher kernenergie gegner zum
kernenergie befürworter gewandt denn
natürlich ist es ein schweres unglück
aber das muss man abwägen gegenüber die
risiken anderer am stromerzeugungs
energieumwandlung methoden
risiken die aber durchaus
unterschiedlicher art sind fukushima
beispielsweise hätte so in deutschland
gar nicht stattfinden können große
probleme in fukushima war ja dann dass
die stromversorgung komplett ausgefallen
ist diese konnten ventile nicht mehr
betätigen usw pumpen nicht mehr laufen
lassen
und das lag daran dass die
zwar mehrere notstromdiesel hatten und
auch batterien hatten die standen aber
alle in einem kellerraum der gegen
eindringen von wasser nicht geschützt
war das heißt als die die flutwelle das
niveau von vom erdboden des
maschinenhauses erreicht hat das wasser
da rein gelaufen und da war alles auf
einmal weg bei uns sind die
in gebunkerten system drin die also
bei einer solchen flutwelle nicht außer
kraft gesetzt würden
vor den ereignissen von fukushima
erschütterte die nuklearkatastrophe von
tschernobyl europa und deutschland
bis heute sind die einschätzungen der
daraus resultierenden todesfälle höchst
unterschiedlich die zahlen reichen von
26 bis 100.000 die sehr subjektive wahl
von informationsquellen und die
unterschiede in der datenerhebung
begleitet die atomdebatte ständig auf
beiden seiten
[Musik]
einig scheinen sich die experten
zumindest darüber zu sein dass die
deutschen kernkraftwerke im vergleich
sehr sicher sind
auf der anderen seite muss man auch
ehrlicherweise sagen ist meine meinung
zumindest dass es konkrete risiko wenn
wir die akw in deutschland noch einige
wenige jahre länger betreiben würden als
geplant sicherlich undramatisch wäre im
vergleich zu den anderen ländern der
preis eines weiterbetriebs wird also
ökonomisch und sicherheitsbezogenen von
den verschiedenen lagern unterschiedlich
beziffert doch wie steht's mit den
konsequenzen der nutzung von kernenergie
fürs klima
der klimawandel gehört zu den wohl
größten herausforderungen unserer zeit
angesichts dessen erachten nicht wenige
experten die kernenergie als geringeres
übel das immerhin hilft co2 einzusparen
zuletzt sogar die eu kommission die eu
kommission hat die kernenergie als
nachhaltig eingestuft und das war ein
politischer deal deutschland wollte
unbedingt
erdgas als nachhaltig eingestuft haben
frankreich wollte unbedingt kernenergie
nachhaltigkeit nachhaltig eingestuft
werden und im ergebnis gibt es einen
deal ein deal der aber immerhin zu
weniger co2 im strombereich führen würde
ein unverzichtbares grundgebot der
energiewende ohne dass der klimawandel
kaum wirksam bekämpft werden könnte wie
passt das zusammen mit eurer forderung
jetzt auf diese kernkraftwerke zu
verzichten also welche die wir haben
können also das ist strom den wir
dringend brauchen
und je mehr wir co2 arm strom in diesem
netz haben desto besser
die frage ist was bei der berechnung des
co2 ausstoßes einbezogen wird
kernkraftwerke haben natürlich in der
prozesskette auch co2-emissionen beim
uran bergbau bei der aufarbeitung
es werden eben nicht in allen studien
alle aspekte zur berechnung
gleichermaßen berücksichtigt und das
führt zu sehr unterschiedlichen
ergebnissen
doch selbst bei einberechnung aller
komponenten liegt der co2 ausstoß von
kernkraft unter dem von gas und kohle
die so oft bedrohlich wirkenden weißen
wolken aus den kühltürmen sind eben nur
reiner wasserdampf
kommt der dampf jetzt aus dem reaktor
heraus zweimal dafür drei leitungen das
ist die eine die
nächste und die dritte ist da
da kommt also der wasserdampf richtung
turbine dreht die turbine an die den
generator antreibt und dann kommt strom
raus
ein wirklich problematisches
abfallprodukt der atomaren
stromerzeugung ist allerdings der atome
und
die frage seiner endlagerung
doch wie hoch sind diese risiken im
vergleich zum risiko des treibhausgas
effekt einzuschätzen
in der technikfolgenabschätzung würden
wir sagen aus endlager ist im engeren
sinn keine frage des risikos mehr sonne
einer unter unsicherheit damit können
wir auch umgehen und vielleicht auch zur
erinnerung nicht nur erkläre endlage ist
nun zuschreibung unser risiko sondern
auch die gefahren eines treibers
effekten hochgradig unsicher wir wissen
dass wir hier probleme bekommen werden
klimawandel wie auch atomkraft sind
gleichermaßen große risiken für unsere
gesellschaft der wunsch energie
unabhängiger von russland zu werden
zwingt zu einer neuer abwägung dieser
risiken
kraftwerksdirektor herbert meinecke
kommt zum ende seiner führung durch das
kernkraftwerk gösgen so dann sehen wir
hier die dampfleitung die wir gerade im
reaktorgebäude gesehen haben wie sie
dort richtung maschinen ausgehen
von hier wird der heiße dampf in die
turbine geleitet
der dampf treibt die turbine an die
wiederum den generator antreibt
der wandelt die bewegungsenergie in
strom um wie der dynamo an einem fahrrad
den strom für das licht erzeugt
[Musik]
diese art der stromerzeugung wird in der
schweiz auch weiterhin stattfinden
die mehrheit der schweizer befürworten
das
wegen des krieges in der ukraine ist in
deutschland dazu jetzt eine intensive
diskussion entbrannt die auch neben der
sicherheitsfrage ganz grundsätzliche
antworten zu unserem lebensstil liefern
muss wie wichtig schätzen wir als
gesellschaft freiheit gegenüber
nachhaltigkeit ein wie wichtig ist unser
eigenes wohlbefinden uns gegenüber das
zukünftiger generationen
und hier kann man den rationalen diskurs
über die werte führen und es geht nicht
nur darum was einzelne stakeholder an
interessen einbringen
welches risiko würde die verlängerung
der laufzeiten mit sich bringt und
welches risiko ist eine gesellschaft für
ihren wohlstand für ihre lebensweise
bereit zu tragen die expertinnen in
diesem film kommen zu sehr
unterschiedlichen schlüssen
ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen dass
ein weiterbetrieb der atomkraftwerke
aktuellen situation eben dann auch
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert ist also
dass das risiko davon was von den
atomkraftwerken für einige jahre aus
geht als geringer eingeschätzt wird als
die verluste wirtschaftlich aber eben
auch rein an wohlbefinden für die
haushalte wenn der strom weg fallen
würde mein eindruck ist nicht dass
irgendjemand in der deutschen
atomindustrie morgenluft wittert ich
glaube es ist allen beteiligten völlig
klar die atomkraft hat keine zukunft in
deutschland es ist völlig klar die
letzten atomkraftwerke werden gold
abgeschaltet und daran will auch niemand
mehr rütteln niemand der ernsthaft in
der energiebranche unterwegs ist
umfragezahlen in der bevölkerung
zeichnen ein anderes bild während
bereits im oktober 21 steigende
strompreise auslöser genug waren damit
sich 50 prozent der befragten für eine
verlängerung der laufzeiten aussprachen
stiegen die umfragewerte im märz 22 in
anbetracht des russischen
angriffskrieges auf die ukraine bereits
auf 70 prozent befürworter der
laufzeitenverlängerung
aber das zeitfenster schließt sich
betreiber nennen ende mai als deadline
für eine entscheidung der regierung
danach könnten die notwendigen schritte
nicht mehr rechtzeitig in die wege
geleitet werden um die laufzeiten zu
verlängern und damit deutschland
vielleicht ein wenig unabhängiger von
gas und kohle lieferungen aus russland
zu machen
[Musik]